geht es ihnen heute wie vor allem wer
hat sie angegriffen
mir geht es heute viel besser wie sie
sehen hat mein gesicht starke
verletzungen und es wird zeit brauchen
bis alles verheilt aber das ist nicht so
wichtig ehrlich gesagt weiß ich nicht
wer mich angegriffen hat in russland
gibt es viele menschen viele gruppen die
zu so etwas in der lage sind ich weiß es
wirklich nicht
gerade erst wurde der oppositionsführer
alexej nawalny angegriffen
jetzt sehen sie deinen verbindung ja
natürlich es steht in verbindung mit
meinem politischen handelns wie gesagt
weiß ich nicht genau wer mir das angetan
hat aber ich bin mir sehr sicher dass es
jemand war der macht hat und stark gegen
das ist was ich tue und gegen unsere
politischen aktivitäten die arbeit als
blogger und radiomoderator aber planen
sie auch eine karriere in der politik ja
sicher tatsächlich habe ich eine
weitgreifende definition von politik und
ich denke dass ich selbst das was ich
mit den ressourcen mache die mir bisher
zur verfügung stehen schon als politik
bezeichnen kann
für mich ist es also jetzt schon
richtige politik
seit vergangenem jahr arbeiten sie für
echo moskau das gehört zur staatlichen
firma von gazprom wie frei können sie
tatsächlich berichten
es ist wirklich eine unglaubliche lage
denn ich kann tatsächlich sagen was
immer ich will wissen sie es hat mich
nie getroffen und nie hat mir jemand
gesagt dass ich über irgendetwas nicht
sprechen darf wenn es jemals solche
gespräche geben würde würde ich den
radiosender sofort verlassen
das erste mal das sind diese art und
weise angegriffen worden sind
vor rund einem monat haben sie ist
bereits schon mal versucht mich zu
schlagen aber glücklicherweise war ich
schnell genug und konnte weglaufen
dieses mal aber kamen sie von hinten an
mich heran und ich habe sie nicht
gesehen und dann taten sie mir an was
sie hier sehen
er war nie liegt noch immer im koma
viele oppositionelle sind im exil jetzt
wurden sie verprügelt haben sie das
gefühl putin gewinnt jetzt gegen seine
kritiker meiner meinung nach ist das ein
anzeichen dafür dass er verliert wenn
sie solche angst haben dass sie zu
solchen mitteln greifen scheinen sie zu
merken dass sie verlieren und wir
gewinnen
ich bin also ziemlich glücklich was
aktuell passiert
sie werden also ihre arbeit fortsetzen
natürlich wie schon gesagt es ist ein
anzeichen dafür dass wir gewinnen es
wäre also dumm jetzt aufzuhören jetzt
ist die zeit unsere mühen noch mal zu
verstärken